we have the possibility of developing the
same type of user interface to
test this hymn this theory with
three-dimensional models which can
display all kinds of objects,
whether molecules, wires, but
also vectors and when I
would say with a  simplicity
of implementation which is which is quite
impressive for all those who
are used to building user interfaces
my name is
guillaume santini i am a
lecturer at the university of paris xiii in
computer science
i have a background in  biophysicist i
did a thesis in
molecular modeling where i participated in the
development of a new
theoretical folding model of the
nucleic acids of molecules dna and darren
my name and i know of it i am a
professor at the university pierre  and
marie curie in paris 6 jan that of
biostatistics biophysics therefore of
macromolecules l dna arn protein and
mobilization in particular with
mathematics to our equation  ipe works
in the field of modeling of
biological macromolecules
it is a question of helping finished therefore the
atomic conformation of large
molecules in that there I wanted to
bring a small piece so it is a
small piece a small fragment of the dna
it  so we had to write a
modeling software
it is something very complicated
and very heavy by the
classic modeling software allow to
represent this type of molecules provided
the concept of elastic thread
is absent and they do not allow to
represent  this son in where we
needed this tool as part of
our research
then there are several points that are not
interesting in mathematics
at first from a computer point of view
it's
all the different ways that we have two
programs helping mathematica, that is to
say that we can program very well
as well with an
imperative approach the languages as pasca
knows but we can equal  how to
have other
programming approaches such as
functional programming or approaches that are
based on rewriting
the second interest that I see is
the structure of the notebook which mainly allows you
to detail your ideas
to write them and only sell  to
test them this father of programming and in the
same environment obtaining the results
and the analyzes and therefore there is this
integrated environment aspect in which one
can think about writing a program and
displaying the results which is conducive I
would say effective development but
here I would say that  thanks to the web based
we finally have an effective tool to
develop the help associated with a package
is all the more effective that thanks to
this tool which developed in the wild
bunch
we can today integrate all the
documentation of a package that  we
develop for our own account or
for users thiel is therefore from
this point of view there we have tools which
finally allow us to  to integrate
the packages that we develop
directly into the architecture of
mathematica and then to benefit from
all the flexibility of use
and questions, in particular from the help
that has been implemented in mathematics 1